Trascrizione: Giulia Sgarbossa
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Stadio Allianz Arena
di Monaco di Baviera, 2 luglio 2021.
Forse avete già capito
di cosa sto parlando.
La nazionale italiana di calcio
affronta il Belgio
nel quarto di finale
più atteso dell’Europeo.
Una partita sulla carta ostica,
contro i primi del ranking Fifa
Lukaku, De Bruyne e Courtois.
Insomma una partita
che si preannuncia complicata,
ma lo sappiamo già.
L’Italia di Mancini domina, convince,
e soprattutto vince con un gol di Barella
e poi con l’immancabile
tiro a giro di Lorenzo Insigne.
Il destino però in quella partita
è un po’ beffardo perché al 78′,
tentando uno scatto sulla fascia,
Leonardo Spinazzola,
che fino a quel momento era stato forse
il miglior calciatore di tutto il torneo
si fa male alla gamba sinistra
e si accascia per terra in lacrime.
Infortunio: lesione al tendine d’Achille.
Europeo finito,
fuori dai campi per quattro, cinque mesi.
Come sappiamo però,
questo piccolo imprevisto
non servirà a fermare
la cavalcata trionfale dell’Italia
che batterà prima la Spagna
in semifinale ai rigori,
e poi l’Inghilterra in finale a Wembley,
ai rigori l′11 luglio 2021.
Leonardo Spinazzola,
con tanto di stampelle
perché era infortunato,
sarà il primo degli azzurri
ad essere premiato.
Il capitano Chiellini,
che aveva saltato un paio di partite
per un piccolo infortunio muscolare,
solleva al cielo la seconda
coppa europea della nostra storia.
Insomma tutto è bene quel che finisce bene
l’Italia è campione d’Europa dopo 53 anni
il miracolo di Mancini è compiuto,
ma una domanda sorge comunque spontanea.
L’infortunio lieve di Chiellini
e l’infortunio severo di Spinazzola,
e magari gli infortuni
di quei calciatori che si sono fatti male
poco prima dell’europeo
non hanno potuto trionfare a Wembley
potevano essere previsti
e quindi magari evitati?
La prevenzione degli infortuni è un po’
il Sacro Graal dell’industria dello sport.
Oltre ad avere un impatto significativo
sullo stato mentale e fisico degli atleti,
gli infortuni generano
anche un grande impatto economico.
Pensate che alcuni ricercatori spagnoli
hanno scoperto che soltanto nelle prime
due divisioni maschili spagnole,
la Liga e la Segunda División,
gli infortuni generano almeno
il 16% di assenze sul lavoro,
chiamiamole così, in termini
di mancate partite,
o sessioni di allenamento
con un costo pari quasi a 200 milioni
in una sola stagione di stipendi
pagati a vuoto, diciamo così.
Senza includere i costi di riabilitazione,
i costi quindi delle spese mediche
e i costi legati all’immagine dell’atleta
oppure della squadra.
Ma allora è possibile
prevederli questi infortuni?
E se sì, come possiamo fare?
Ora, nell’era dell’informazione,
della tecnologia, dei Big Data,
dell’Internet delle cose,
viene naturale rivolgersi
innanzitutto alla tecnologia.
Oggi, in quasi tutti gli sport
professionistici,
le performances degli atleti
vengono monitorate
da una miriade
di dispositivi elettronici e sensori:
GPS, accelerometri e giroscopi
solo per menzionare alcuni,
che vengono generalmente inseriti,
incastrati in delle pettorine,
che sono come dei reggiseni.
In inglese vengono chiamati
sport bras, reggiseni sportivi,
che sono però molto comodi da indossare
al di sotto della maglia da gioco.
Ora questi sensori
sono in grado di monitorare praticamente
tutti i movimenti dell’atleta,
ricostruendo una traiettoria
apparentemente caotica
ma dalla quale è possibile estrarre
dei parametri dettagliatissimi:
dalla distanza totale percorsa
dall’atleta, alla velocità media,
alle accelerazioni e decelerazioni
in ogni singolo movimento,
al tempo speso
ad una determinata velocità
e altri centinaia di parametri fisici.
Riusciamo quindi a comporre
un mosaico sostanzialmente completo
dello sforzo fisico di un atleta
durante una sessione di allenamento,
durante una partita o durante una gara.
Ora però sia chiaro che questi dati
sono pressoché inutili,
senza un algoritmo
che li sappia manipolare,
processare e interpretare
in modo automatico
allo scopo di associare a questi
parametri una probabilità di infortunio.
Ora ora che ci penso bene
un algoritmo esiste
ed è ancora comunemente utilizzato
da moltissime società sportive.
Si chiama metodo dell’acuto cronico,
che è un termine difficile
per dire che prendiamo
uno dei parametri fisici citati
e ne calcoliamo due semplicissimi numeri:
il valore acuto,
che è il valore medio di quel parametro
per quel atleta nell’ultima settimana;
e il valore cronico,
che è il valore medio di quel parametro
per quel atleta nell’ultimo mese.
Se il valore acuto è circa
il doppio di quello cronico,
cioè se lo sforzo dell’atleta
nell’ultima settimana
è molto maggiore
di quello tipico del mese,
allora il metodo lancia un allarme:
alto rischio di infortunio.
Questo metodo però ha un piccolo problema:
la maggior parte delle volte
che lancia un allarme, è un falso allarme.
Nel 95% dei casi in cui l’atleta
può trovarsi in quella fascia critica
di acuto cronico dove potrebbe farsi male,
in realtà non si farà male.
Cioè più di 9 volte su 10
l’algoritmo non è attendibile.
Qualcuno di voi
si prenderebbe la responsabilità
di lasciare Leo Messi in panchina
nella semifinale di Champions
PSG-Barcellona, una a caso,
perché un algoritmo ha suggerito
che forse potrebbe farsi male
ma non è nemmeno poi così sicuro?
Una sola staff di una società così
importante vorrebbe un metodo più preciso
su cui basare delle decisioni,
magari anche una spiegazione del perché
sarebbe saggio risparmiare un po’
Messi in quella semifinale.
Quando il problema annoso
della previsione degli infortuni
fu proposto da un club
di calcio professionistico
al mio team di ricerca CNR,
ci fu subito evidente
che un predittore di infortuni non era
un qualcosa che potevamo programmare noi
a mano alla vecchia maniera.
Ma data la complessità del problema
e la numerosità delle variabili in gioco
dovevamo delegarlo
a un algoritmo
di intelligenza artificiale.
La cosa bella
dell’intelligenza artificiale
è che fa quasi tutto da sola.
Bisogna però fornire
degli esempi opportuni da cui imparare
e calibrarla in modo opportuno.
Cosa che chiaramente è facile a dirsi
ma non è facile a farsi,
perché richiede una grande esperienza
e una grande conoscenza
e soprattutto la raccolta dei dati.
Ed è proprio quello che abbiamo fatto noi.
Abbiamo fatto un lungo
esperimento scientifico
durante il quale abbiamo monitorato
le prestazioni di decine
di calciatori professionisti
attraverso le pettorine
per poter ricavare uno storico
dei parametri fisici di ogni atleta
per ogni sessione d’allenamento,
per ogni partita, per ogni gara.
Abbiamo quindi ricostruito
quello che nella scienza dei dati
si chiama comunemente
insieme di addestramento,
training set per gli anglofoni,
che è un insieme in cui ogni allenamento
viene descritto da un insieme
di parametri fisici e un’etichetta,
cioè un numero che ci indica
se quel calciatore
effettivamente si farà male di lì a breve,
nella prossima partita o nella successiva
sessione di allenamento, per esempio.
Quindi allenamenti con parametri fisici
etichetta, allenamento-etichetta, ecc.
Migliaia di questi esempi li abbiamo dati
in pasto a un'intelligenza artificiale
che li ha esaminati uno a uno,
li ha processati uno a uno,
li ha elaborati uno a uno,
per rilevare in modo automatico
schemi, correlazioni,
associazioni dei dati,
e generare un predittore di infortuni.
La grande poesia
dell’intelligenza artificiale:
algoritmi che imparano dai dati
a generare altri algoritmi
che nel nostro caso
è il predittore di infortuni
ovvero un classificatore,
tecnicamente parlando,
che è in grado di leggere lo storico
degli allenamenti di un calciatore,
calcolare una probabilità di infortuni
e suggerire se magari è meglio che Messi
lo facciamo entrare solo nel secondo tempo
oppure che lo sostituiamo
il prima possibile.
Quando abbiamo, dopo mesi di lavoro,
ottenuto finalmente
il predittore di infortuni
abbiamo contattato il club
professionistico con grande entusiasmo,
il quale ha ascoltato
quello che avevamo da dire,
ha esaminato il predittore
e ci ha detto: “Ottimo lavoro, ma ci sono
una buona notizia e una cattiva notizia”.
La buona notizia
è che il predittore di infortuni
ha una precisione sorprendente,
è circa 10 volte più preciso
del metodo acuto cronico di cui sopra.
Una simulazione al computer
che abbiamo condotto,
simulando un’intera stagione sportiva,
ha dimostrato che seguendo con cura
i suggerimenti del predittore
la società potrebbe almeno
dimezzare gli infortuni muscolari
durante una stagione.
Niente male.
Ma c’è pure la cattiva notizia,
e la cattiva notizia è
che una previsione da sola non basta.
Se noi non forniamo allo staff tecnico
di una società sportiva
anche un’indicazione del perché
quel giocatore potrebbe farsi male,
lo staff tecnico non può riformulare
i piani di allenamento
allo scopo di ridurre il rischio
di infortuni ed evitare l’infortunio.
Allo stesso modo un atleta, un calciatore
vorrebbe sapere il perché si è fatto male
per poter evitare l’infortunio nel futuro.
Un semplice algoritmo
che restituisce solo una probabilità
senza una spiegazione a contorno
è inutile ai fini pratici.
In altre parole, il nostro predittore
doveva anche essere interpretabile,
cioè fornire oltre a una previsione,
precisa chiaramente,
anche un insieme di regole,
di istruzioni, di ragionamenti
approssimati della macchina
che poi lo staff avrebbe corroborato
con altre informazioni
con la loro grande
esperienza insostituibile
e magari con informazioni
sull’aspetto psicologico motivazionale
per prendere alla fine poi
una decisione informata,
e capire se Messi può giocare
senza rischi oppure no.
Regole anche abbastanza semplici
come il giocatore si è sforzato troppo
su questo parametro fisico,
e troppo poco su questo,
e tende a infortunarsi.
Ok allora magari c’è un allarme.
Magari c’è un altro calciatore
che si è sforzato poco
in tutti i parametri,
allora è sicuro.
Cose molto semplici, che sono piaciute
molto al club professionistico
con cui stiamo collaborando.
Però la domanda è cosa
ci facciamo noi con questo predittore.
Bè il predittore di infortuni,
preciso e spiegabile,
è il primo passo verso quella
che possiamo definire
una manutenzione predittiva degli atleti,
nella quale i sensori e gli algoritmi
si mescolano in un sistema intelligente
in continua evoluzione che monitora,
in tempo quasi reale,
lo stato fisico e anche
la probabilità di infortunio.
OK, questo funziona bene per il calcio,
e per gli altri sport?
E per noi, voi più che altro,
atleti amatoriali?
Per i calcettisti del lunedì
e i ciclisti della domenica?
Per chi magari vuole preparare
una mezza maratona senza infortunarsi?
Ora guardate, l’intelligenza artificiale
è talmente flessibile e potente
nel rilevare le associazioni,
gli schemi nei dati,
che può essere applicata
in qualsiasi contesto.
Inoltre ormai abbiamo sensori
che possono monitorare
tutti gli aspetti dello sforzo fisico.
E ne avremo ancora di più dettagliati,
avremo sensori per monitorare
l’alimentazione, la glicemia,
lo stress psicologico.
Quindi possiamo e potremo ancora meglio
monitorare le performance
di podisti, ciclisti, alpinisti,
sciatori, tennisti, calcettisti e,
registrando anche tutti gli infortuni,
possiamo addestrare un predittore
di infortuni virtualmente per ogni sport.
Certo, per qualche sport funzionerà meglio
e per qualche altro funzionerà peggio.
Non lo sappiamo ancora perché
è ancora tutto da scoprire, ma volendo,
possiamo creare un predittore
di infortuni per qualsiasi sport.
Ma non solo,
perché ormai i sensori sono a un costo
così basso che sono alla portata di tutti.
Possiamo comprare le nostre pettorine
e i nostri braccialetti biometrici
per addestrare il nostro personale
predittore di infortuni
che ci fornirà le nostre personali regole
e ragionamenti da consultare,
magari insieme al nostro
preparatore medico di fiducia,
per fare la nostra partita
di calcetto del lunedì
però magari evitando la lesione al tendine
d’Achille che può sempre accadere.
Guardate, siamo a un passo così
dal Sacro Graal
e da una manutenzione predittiva
degli atleti professionisti
e non professionisti
che ci porterà ad avere
innanzitutto prestazioni sempre migliori
ma soprattutto sempre più sicure.
Perché nello sport,
come del resto nella vita,
prevedere e spiegare
sono sempre meglio che curare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)